recuerdan que en el vídeo pasado
llegamos a esta expresión de la integral
la cual correspondía al volumen del
suelo de revolución que estábamos
buscando de esta región que vamos a
crear alrededor de la recta y es igual a
4 pues bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer en
esta ocasión es encontrar el valor de
esta integral y para esto pues hay que
hacer todas las cuentas correspondientes
así que lo primero que voy a hacer es
tomarme este polinomio y elevarlo al
cuadrado por lo tanto tengo 4 - x
cuadrada mejor déjenme ponerlo de forma
ascendente para que sea mucho más fácil
y ya tenerlo de una vez simplificado
entonces es menos x cuadrada más 2 x más
4 lo único que hice fue acomodar este
polinomio con el grado mayor al
principio y para elevarlo al cuadrado
hay que multiplicarlo por sí mismo por
lo tanto lo único que hay que hacer es
la multiplicación de polinomio por
polinomio y que me va a quedar empecemos
por el 4x4 bueno 4x4 16 después es 4 por
2x que es 8 x 4 x menos equis cuadrada
es menos 4 x cuadrada menos 4 x cuadrada
y después vamos con el segundo término
2x por 4 es 8 x 2 x x 2 x es 4
cuadrada positivo y 2x x - x cuadrada es
lo mismo que menos 2x cúbica y ahora
vamos con el tercer término y me queda
menos x cuadrada por 4 pues es lo mismo
que menos 4x cuadrada no es así menos 4x
cuadrada y después menos equis cuadrada
por 2x es lo mismo que menos 2x cúbica y
después tengo menos x cuadrada por menos
x cuadrada lo cual me da positivo x
cuarta equis cuarta positiva y bueno
ahora sí voy a simplificar toda esta
multiplicación de polinomios haciendo la
respectiva sumas y restas por lo tanto
vamos haciéndolo con cuidado para que no
me equivoque x 4a menos 4x cúbica y
después este con este se van y me queda
solamente menos 4 x cuadrada y después 8
x 8 x positivos los dos son 16 x y
después solamente bajó el 16 bueno esto
es en una primera parte cuando yo elevé
4 - es cuadrada más 2 x elevado al
cuadrado ahora lo que voy a hacer es 4 -
x elevado al cuadrado que es el segundo
binomio que tenemos que elevar al
cuadrado
y por lo tanto 4x4 de 16 4 x - x me va a
dar menos 4 x después menos x por 4 pues
es menos 4x y al último menos x x menos
x que me da x cuadrada y esto sí lo
simplificamos un poco me va a quedar x
cuadrada después menos 4 x menos 4 x es
menos 8x y después más 16 y bueno
entonces en esta integral hay que hacer
la diferencia entre el primer resultado
menos el segundo resultado por lo tanto
a éste le voy a cambiar el signo
entonces me va a quedar todo esto menos
y entre paréntesis x cuadrada menos 8 x
más 16 por lo tanto hay que multiplicar
por menos esta expresión o cambiarles el
signo por lo tanto me queda menos x
cuadrada más 8 x menos 16 y ahora sí voy
a hacer otra vez la operación de estos
dos polinomios para ver mi resultado que
voy a integrar y para no hacer más
relajo déjenme poner el resultado aquí
abajo para que lo podamos integrar
entonces x cuarta pues no tienen nadie
con quién sumarse ni restar se entonces
se queda igual lo mismo pasa con menos
4x cúbica y después menos 4x cuadrada -
x cuadrada me queda
5 x cuadrado 16 x 8 x es 24 x y estos
dos vamonos se van a un positivo y el
negativo iguales se cancelan y entonces
lo que tengo que hacer es la integral de
esta expresión que tengo aquí la
integral de dónde a dónde a bueno de 0 a
recuerden que mi límite de integración
superior era 3 y después hay que
multiplicar todo esto por de x así que
vamos a buscar las anti derivadas para
resolver esta integral esperen me falta
pi 15 sin aquel que pone también a pi y
lo voy a sacar fuera integral porque
recuerden que es una constante
georges y voy a calcular toda la anti
derivada que tenemos aquí por lo tanto
me queda pi que multiplica a quien bueno
la anti derivada de x cuarta es x quinta
entre 5 recuerden que le sumamos una el
exponente y lo dividimos entre ese mismo
número
después me quedan menos 4 x elevado a la
cuarta entre 4 por lo tanto el 44 se van
y solamente me queda menos x cuarta
después me queda menos 5 x elevado al
cubo entre 3 es decir menos 5 tercios de
x cúbica recuerden que le sumamos 1 el
exponente y lo dividimos entre ese mismo
número después me queda
4 x cuadrada entre 2 pero 24 entre 2 es
lo mismo que 12 por lo tanto al final me
queda más 12 x cuadrada y todo esto
espero no esperen todo esto hay que
evaluarlo de dónde a dónde lo tenemos
que evaluar en dos límites de
integración por lo tanto le voy a poner
el corchetes recuerden que los corchetes
indican que vamos a evaluar esto en 0 y
en 3 y entonces vamos a hacerlo si te
das cuenta lo primero que hay que hacer
es evaluarlo en el índice superior es
decir en 3 por lo tanto vamos a ponerlo
3 elevado a la quinta entre 5 3 elevado
a la quinta en 35 cuánto es 3 por 3 9
por 3 27 por 381 a ver déjenme
escribirlo 3 al cubo es lo mismo que 27
eso lo sabemos 3 elevado a la cuarta es
lo mismo que 81 y 3 elevado a la quinta
es 81 por 3 entonces me queda tres por
una es 3 y 3 por 8 24 243 entonces es
243 quintos 243 quintos y después que me
va a quedar menos x cuarta evaluado el
32 mismo que 81 entonces me queda menos
81 menos 5 tercios de x cúbica por lo
tanto vamos a escribirlo
evaluado en el 3 me queda menos 5
tercios de x elevado al cubo pero cuando
lo sustituimos por 3 me queda 3 elevado
al cubo lo cual es 27 pero bueno esto se
puede simplificar un poco porque 27 y 3
se pueden dividir entonces 27 entre 3 me
dan 9 y por 5 me da 45 mejor escribo en
lugar de todo esto directamente 45 si es
que no nos dimos cuenta el 3 iba a
eliminar con uno de estos 13 si me
quedaba 5 por x al cuadrado es decir 5
por 9 que era 45 y bueno ahora voy a
sustituir el 3 en la última expresión y
me queda 12 por 9 lo cual es 108 y ya
con esto acabo con el 3 y después a esto
hay que quitarle la evaluación en cero
sin embargo si te das cuenta cuando
nosotros ponemos 000 kaiser acá al final
todo esto me resulta cero por lo tanto
ni hay que hacerlo ni hay que
complicarnos la vida solamente hay que
realizar toda esta operación que tenemos
aquí y por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo me
queda factor izado y toda esta parte que
tengo aquí cuánto es menos 81 menos 45
más 108 pues la podemos hacer no
entonces lo primero que voy a hacer es
menos 81 menos 40
5 los 2 negativos y los voy a sumar por
lo tanto me queda menos 126 negativo 126
ya esto le voy a sumar 108 ok entonces
lo que voy a hacer es 126 menos 108 lo
cual me da 18 entonces el resultado de
menos 126 más 108 es 18 pero 18 negativo
a esto le tenemos que sumar 243 quintos
déjenme ver si lo hice bien menos 81
menos 45 es menos 126 ajá más 108 me va
a dar 18 porque 18 y 108 es 126 en
efecto y bueno a esto hay que sumarle
243 quintos por lo tanto voy a escribir
el menos 18 en quintos y menos 18 en
quintos es lo mismo que 90 quintos
porque 5 por 18 es 90 entonces esto ya
está mucho más fácil me queda pi que
multiplica a 243 quintos 243 quintos ya
esto le voy a quitar mis 90 quintos que
me salieron del resultado de menos 81
menos 45 más 108 y esto cuánto es igual
y que multiplica a 243 menos 90 243
menos 90 es lo mismo que 153 entonces es
153 entre 5 o dicho de otra manera esto
es lo mismo que 153 y quintos 153 pi
quintos y lo hemos logrado por fin
sacamos el volumen que queríamos el
volumen si se acuerdan de lo que vimos
en el vídeo pasado de esta básica
extraña que yo tenía aquí que era un
sólido de revolución